de yenín en la cisjordania ocupada
proceden los dos sospechosos del ataque
de anoche en el ate en el centro de
israel que causó la muerte de al menos
tres israelíes según la radio operada
por las fuerzas de defensa de israel
ninguno de los atacantes se había
involucrado o antes en actividades
terroristas ni contaban tampoco con
ninguna afiliación no obstante ello no
ha evitado que jamás esté en el centro
de los señalamientos de políticos
israelíes luego de que el grupo
aplaudiera el ataque y luego de que su
líder ya just in war animar hace una
semana a tomar una pistola un cuchillo o
hasta un hacha y este último elemento es
el que se cree que usó uno de los
agresores en respuesta al primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett dijo
que los responsables y quienes nos
ayudaron pagarán el precio mientras que
eeuu condenó lo ocurrido y la unión
europea- pidió el cese de la violencia
una violencia que como lamento el
presidente de la autoridad palestina
mahmud abbas sólo lleva a un deterioro
mayor de la situación cuyo centro de
tensión ahora está la mezquita de
al-aqsa por la renovación de las visitas
de judíos y el temor de que se rompa el
estatus que reserva el espacio sólo al
culto musulmán en este contexto israel
extendió el cierre de los pasos con gaza
y cisjordania hasta este próximo domingo
desde finales de marzo 18 israelíes han
muerto en 6 ataques y más de 20
palestinos han fallecido en redadas y
otros actos de las fuerzas israelíes